[Musique]
on peut pas nier qu'on est passé de 800
à 3700 déclarations de pénurie depuis le
premier le rapport du Sénat l'été 2018
on parle des médicaments donc c'est pas
bien de consommation ordinaire et donc
chacun a sa responsabilité éthique dans
cette question voilà et donc c'est une
question qui n'est pas que nationale qui
est européenne qui internationale le
rapport de force ne devrait pas exister
on doit en tout cas donner un poids
important au considérations sanitaire
dans les décisions de la part des
laboratoires de ceux qui fabriquent il y
a un contrepoids on considération
financière inobéissent pas tout à fait
aux objectifs sanitaires et de santé
publique qui a énormément d'aide qui
sont donnés à l'industrie pharmaceutique
le rapport met en évidence et 710
millions d'euros donc à partir du moment
où il y a aide public que c'est
considéré comme les industriels à juste
titre comme très attractifs pour
l'implantation en France il faut que le
service rendu soit à la hauteur et
répondre réellement aux besoins des
Françaises et des Français parce qu'ils
a pris le lead dans la communication
publique depuis plusieurs années c'est
de dire 80% des principes actifs sont
produits en Inde en Chine en fait on a
cherché nous à sortir de ce sujet là
parce que on fabrique certains principes
actifs en France et pour autant on a des
pénuries derrière il faut absolument
qu'il y ait une meilleure prise en
compte aussi de l'échelon de proximité
c'est piloter un peu au niveau national
mais il n'y a pas suffisamment de liens
avec ce qui se passe région par région
on l'a vu par exemple au moment de la
pénurie de la pilule à bordive donc il
faut qu'il y ait une coordination entre
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et par exemple les ARS ça
c'est important et puis on a le
sentiment qu'il y a beaucoup d'agences
qu'elle travaille mais un peu chacune
dans leur coin et que donc il faut un
pilote dans l'avion c'est pour ça qu'on
propose un secrétariat général sur les
questions de médicaments et qui
permettent aussi de mettre en oeuvre la
fabrication et la maîtrise publique d'un
certain nombre de médicaments sous la
houlette de la GEPS